debatte zum thema sterbehilfe morgen
eine regierungserklärung von olaf scholz
und alles weitere erzählt ihnen jetzt
meine kollegin katharina kühn in berlin
ja und jetzt inne auf der tagesordnung
steht hier gleich die befragung der
bundesregierung
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil ist
heute hier eingeladen 60 minuten lang
haben dann die abgeordneten zeit ihn zu
befragen nachdem er eine kurze
einführung hier gegeben hat der
arbeitsminister hat natürlich viele
verschiedene baustellen so kann man das
nennen die altenpflege die grundrente
dem mindestlohn von 12 euro möchte er
einführen aber zum beispiel auch die
arbeitsbedingungen in bestimmten
bereichen verbessern unter anderen die
paketboten sollen faire zu fairen
arbeitsbedingungen
arbeiten können und eine der
interessantesten nachrichten für
bürgerinnen und der rente dürfte ist
kürzlich erst gegeben haben die
koalition hat sich auf die größe
rentenerhöhung seit jahrzehnten geeinigt
zum ersten juli sollen die altersbezüge
im westen um 5,35 prozent steigen im
osten um
6,12 prozent das ist der stärkste
anstieg im osten seit 1994 im westen
sogar seit
1983 also eine deutliche steigerung
wobei man muss ja auch immer die
aktuelle lage in den blick nehmen und da
gibt es dann trotzdem kritik daran dass
einige sozialverbände und gewerkschaften
kritisieren dass wegen der hohen
inflation viele rentnerinnen und rentner
von dieser erhöhung kaum profitieren
dürften sondern dass eben die
gestiegenen energiepreise die
gestiegenen
preise für lebensmittel kaum dazu führen
könnten dass die rentnerin und rentner
wirklich etwas von dieser erhöhten rente
haben 21 millionen rentnerinnen und
rentnern gibt es in deutschland also
eine große anzahl an personen die das
interessiert und bundesarbeitsminister
hubertus heil startet jetzt mit seinen
eingehenden äußerungen damen und herren
putins krieg gegen die ukraine
erschüttert unseren gesamten kontinents
und die folgen sind unabsehbar
die menschen in der ukraine das
ukrainische volk
verteidigt seine souveränität und seine
freiheit wir sind auch die werte die das
mit uns verbindet nämlich europäische
werte dafür zu sorgen dass auf unserem
kontinent die stärke des rechts auf das
völkerrecht gilt und nicht das recht des
stärkeren
ich erwähne das deshalb weil in meinen
einleitenden worten die ich ihnen
berichten will über die schwerpunkte die
wir im krisen management angesichts
dieses furchtbaren krise im bereich des
ministeriums für arbeit und soziales uns
vorgenommen haben seit dem 24
februar haben wir uns drei dinge
vorgenommen zum einen gilt ist und das
ist meine abends verantwortung
mitzuhelfen dass auch in dieser krise
nach zwei jahren corona krise wir
versuchen den arbeitsmarkt in
deutschland robust und intakt zu halten
wir leben das in der korona zeit das
gelungen ist dass trotz der tiefsten
wirtschaftskrise unsere generation hier
mit instrumenten wie dem instrument der
kurzarbeit millionen von arbeitsplätzen
sichern konnten das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit gewesen aber es
war ein richtiger weg für unternehmen
fachkräfte an bord zu halten für
beschäftigte arbeitsplätze zu sichern
und auch die gesamtwirtschaftliche
nachfrage damit zu stabilisieren nach
dem 24 februar haben wir weitere
maßnahmen ergriffen wir haben jetzt
nicht mehr damit zu tun dass
arbeitsplätze sehr gefährdet sind in
bereichen die früher durch corona
maßnahmen eingeschränkt waren sondern
wir haben jetzt vor allen dingen im
industriellen bereich damit zu tun dass
es wiederum zu störungen von
lieferketten gibt da fehlen kabelbäume
aus der ukraine für die
automobilproduktion oder rohstoffe aus
russland und deshalb haben wir weiterhin
auch maßnahmen zur kurzarbeit verlängert
um beschäftigung zu sichern und die
zahlen am arbeitsmarkt geben uns recht
der deutsche arbeitsmarkt ist sehr sehr
im takt robust die sozialversicherung
die beschäftigung wächst sogar wieder
der zweite schwerpunkt meine damen und
herren ist in der letzten sitzungswoche
hier sehr intensiv debattiert worden
nämlich die tatsache dass dieser krieg
die ohnehin schon gestiegene
preisentwicklung massiv gepostet hat wir
haben erlebt dass vor allen dingen durch
diesen krieg energie importe teurer
geworden sind und das schlägt sich in
lebenshaltungskosten für bürgerinnen und
bürger nieder deshalb war und ist es das
ziel der bundesregierung gezielt
menschen mit unteren und mittleren
einkommen zu entlasten und das haben wir
auch weiterhin im blick ich will an
dieser stelle sagen das ist aber auch
wichtig ist dass du etwas für
geringverdiener tun und ich bin diesem
deutschen bundestag deshalb sehr sehr
dankbar dass der ausschuss für arbeit
soziales am heutigen tag dafür gesorgt
hat dass der mindestlohn ab erster
oktober um 12 auf 12 euro steigen wird
das ist eine lohnerhöhung für viele
menschen für 6,5 millionen menschen in
deutschland von 22 prozent das ist
ohnehin sinnvoll aber es hilft auch in
zeiten gestiegener preise besser über
die runden zu kommen für sehr sehr
fleißige menschen und das dritte
was ich ansprechen möchte dass neben der
frage wie wir den arbeitsmarkt intakt
halten was wir tun um vor allen dingen
untere und mittlere einkommen zu
entlasten ist die große aufgabe
mit der großen zahl von geflüchteten die
aus der ukraine zu uns gekommen sind
anständig umzugehen auch da ist
sozialpolitik arbeitsmarktpolitik sehr
stark gefragt wir haben hier im
deutschen bundestag beschlossen dass ab
erster juni die geflüchteten aus der
ukraine weil sie einen unmittelbaren
schutzstatus haben gleichgestellt werden
mit anerkannten asylbewerber und damit
von den grund sicherungssystemen betreut
werden das entlastet länder und kommunen
milliarden schwer die wir nicht im regen
stehen lassen als wohnt aber es hilft
vor allen dingen geflüchteten
unmittelbar weil sie jetzt den vollen
schutz beispielsweise der
krankenversicherung haben aber es hilft
auch meine damen und herren geflüchtete
besser in den arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren werden die rechtlichen
voraussetzungen für den zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt um selber geschossen und
wir werden jetzt praktische hürden
beiseite räumen ich war gestern hier im
welcome center der deutschen bahn ag
unmittelbar vor dem hauptbahnhof in
berlin deutsche bahn ag engagiert sich
zusammen mit der bundesagentur für
arbeit dafür dass geflüchtet die hier
arbeiten finden können ich habe zwei
frauen kennengelernt denen das geholfen
hat eine die bei der ukrainischen bahn
gearbeitet hat und jetzt als
elektrikerin bei der deutschen bahn ag
eine arbeit gefunden hat und eine die
als juristin ihrer heimat gearbeitet hat
und jetzt bei der deutschen bahn ag mit
hilft tatsächlich auch andere fachkräfte
anzuwerben das sind zwei kleine
beispiele aber es wird eine große
anstrengung der wir vor allen dingen
dafür sorgen müssen dass die menschen
zugang zur sprache haben dass wir
berufsanerkennung beschleunigen dass
kinderbetreuung gewährleistet ist und
dass wir den menschen tatsächlich eine
ordentliche perspektive auch auf dem
arbeitsmarkt geben zusammenfassend also
wir sind als arbeitsministerium stark in
krisen management auch involviert wir
versuchen aber aus der krise immer auch
fortschritt zu machen denn das was wir
zb bei der beschleunigten
berufsanerkennung für den arbeitsmarkt
jetzt gut hinkriegen brauchen wir
übrigens dauerhaft auch für die reform
des fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetzes
also krise meistern und fortschritt
machen das ist unser motto jetzt freue
ich mich auf ihre frage
vielen dank herr minister wir beginnen
die regierungsbefragung zu den
einleitenden ausführungen des ministers
und zum geschäftsbereich sowie zu den
vorangegangenen kabinettssitzungen und
mit allgemeinen fragen das wort hat
zuerst aus der cdu/csu-fraktion kritiker
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
minister bei der anhörung zum
sanktionsmoratorium am vergangenen
montag hat der chef der bundesagentur
verarbeitet das schälen gesagt dass es
weiterhin sanktionen braucht um zitat
von ihm mit besonders schweren fällen
weiterhin in kontakt zu sein ich kann
mich auch gut erinnern dass sie so
ähnlich argumentiert haben damals vor
dem bundesverfassungsgericht da durfte
damals mit dabei sein
jetzt führen sie ein sanktionsmoratorium
ein wo sie die sanktionen de facto
weitestgehend abschaffen haben sie ihre
meinung zur sanktionen geändert
der apotheker ich habe meine meinung
nicht geändert ich teile die haltung
dass wir vor allen dingen auch
mitwirkungspflichten brauchen und die
ihre darstellung ist ja nicht ganz
richtig die koalition hat auf den weg
gebracht die parlamentarier wenn jetzt
diese woche das glaub ich im bundestag
auch beschließen dass wir für ein jahr
ein sogenanntes sanktionsmoratorium
haben das heißt mitwirkungspflichten
werden in vielen bereichen tatsächlich
anders gehandhabt es gibt aber
beispielsweise für meldeversäumnisse
immer noch in bei wiederholten
meldeversäumnissen auch die möglichkeit
zur leistungs bindung von bis zu zehn
prozent und die große reform steht vor
uns das bürgergeld und da ist es
tatsächlich so dass wir nicht nur die
das urteil des verfassungsgerichts dass
wir uns ja alle miteinander angefangen
haben sie ja auch umsetzen müssen
sondern dass wir ein neues system
schaffen ein system in dem wir auf mehr
vertrauen setzen aber ich bleibe dabei
in extremen fällen wird es auch
mitwirkungspflichten geben und auch die
möglichkeit zur leistungsminderung ich
glaube die koalitionsabgeordnete haben
sich verständigt dass das bis zu 30
prozent entsprechend des urteils des
bundesverfassungsgerichts auch möglich
sein wird über die ausgestaltung ist zu
reden insofern ein ich habe meine
meinung nicht der theoretiker aber wir
werden das system grundlegend verändern
entbürokratisieren und den menschen mehr
zutrauen
sie haben das recht zu einer nachbarn
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
minister wenn sie dankenswerterweise
hier klarstellen dass sie weiterhin für
sanktionen sind dann möchte ich noch mal
die frage stellen warum sie jetzt aber
für zwölf monate die sanktionen de facto
aussetzen nur um sie dann wieder
einzuführen welche logik steht denn da
bitteschön dahinter ist sie verwirren
damit die die die mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter in den jobcentern zu lasten
ihm jetzt unnötig etwas auf und sie
stören auch das rechtsempfinden der
meisten bürgerinnen und bürger war jetzt
sanktionen ausgesetzt werden obwohl es
eigentlich konsequenzen für
fehlverhalten dürfte und wollen sie in
zwölf monaten wieder einführen welche
logik steht dahinter ich bin sehr
dankbar für die frage weil ich glaube
die mitarbeiterin mittlerweile ein
jobcenter nicht sehr verwirrt sind aber
zur aufklärung von ihnen kann ich
beitragen denn tatsächlich werden wir
ein neues
ich glaube das ist ganz klug ist dass
diese koalition sich vorgenommen hat im
vorfeld der einführung des bürgergeldes
was ja nicht einfach die fortführung des
bisherigen systems ist sondern in vieler
hinsicht eine grundlegende reform sollen
wird anders mit diesem thema umzugehen
und ich will es dann ein beispiel machen
denn das ist teil des vorhabens des
bürgergeldes wir werden reformieren die
bisherige eingliederungsvereinbarung die
war gut gemeint aber praktiker aus den
jobcentern sagen das ist ein bisschen zu
einem textbaustein kasten geworden aber
es ist wahnsinnig verrechtlicht ich
glaube dass herr bitter wenn wir
gemeinsam aus fachpolitiker gut darüber
reden diese bürgergeld reform eine
chance ist die
polarisierte debatte über sanktionen und
mitwirkungspflichten endlich zu
entgiften in deutschland es ist genauso
falsch alle langzeitarbeitslosen
unter den verdacht zu stellen sie seien
zu faul zu arbeiten und dieses signal
darf der sozialstaat nicht geben das war
immer nicht richtig und auf der anderen
seite ist es auch nicht statthaft wenn
ein sozialstaat
mitwirkungspflichten erwartet und das
auch rechtsfolgen hat und das werden wir
genau so umsetzen wie es beschrieben
habe
vielen dank gibt es zum gleichen thema
nachfragen
aus der cdu/csu-fraktion kollege
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister die hubertus heil
ich fand ihre erklärungen jetzt sehr
spannend weil ich glaube wir müssten
auch der bevölkerung auch erklären wenn
jemand eine zumutbare arbeit nicht
annimmt aber jemand anders hart arbeitet
und wir reden glaube ich alle im
parlament und sie auch davon die
altenpflegerin und die wirklich einen
einen wichtigen job für die gesellschaft
macht und der andere der eben sagt aus
welchen gründen auch immer ich mache
diesen job nicht wie erklären sie dann
dass wir dann eben hier bei den
sanktionen jetzt eben nicht mehr so
handeln wie wir es als cdu csu fraktion
weiter handeln würden deswegen können
sie uns das oder können sie es mir aber
können sie es vor allem auch der
altenpflegerin erklären
das kann ich herr kollege und ich finde
es wichtig das finde ich gruppen am
arbeitsmarkt gegeneinander ausspielen
denn der realität
denn in der realität geht es hier nicht
darum dass menschen nicht mitwirken
müssen ich habe ja vorhin beschrieben
wir werden das thema einem wiederum ganz
neu aufstellen
und mein ziel bleibt es nicht menschen
in der grundsicherung oder dann ein
bürgergeld zu verwalten sondern wo immer
es geht raus zu bringen aber wenn sie
mit den praktikern in den jobcentern
reden dann sagen sie mir zwei sachen wir
bringen dich mit sanktionen die leute
raus sondern wird brücken hat den
nachteil auf den arbeitsmarkt zwar
richtigen brücken weil zb zwei drittel
der langzeitarbeitslosen menschen keinen
abgeschlossenen berufsabschluss haben da
werden wir etwas neues einführen an
dieser stelle weil wir wollen sie nicht
in irgendwelche arbeit bringen sondern
nachhaltig in ordentliche arbeit bringen
und das zweite ist ja wir brauchen für
ganz ganz harte fälle das sind übrigens
die seltensten auch möglichkeiten das
mit berufspflichten bleiben und dass das
rechtsfolgen hat auch
leistungsminderungen das habe ich eben
beschrieben das werden sie sehen aber
bitte nicht die altenpflegerin gegen den
langzeitarbeitslosen ausspielen die
meisten langzeitarbeitslosen die ich
kennen wollen arbeiten und sind keine
frauen menschen
sie dürften noch eine nachfrage stellen
aber sie müssen nicht aber ich freue
mich
frau präsidentin das mache ich natürlich
gerne lieber herr minister ich glaube
darum geht es hier in diesem hohen haus
keinem berufsgruppen untereinander
auszuspielen trotzdem frage ich sie
nochmal
empfinden sie das als gerecht und ich
empfinde
sanktionen nicht als ungerecht sondern
ich finde sie als
leistungsfördernd und ich glaube und da
möchte ich sie doch mal noch mal sehr
offen und auch sehr klar um eine antwort
bitte bleiben sie weiterhin bei dem
prinzip fordern und fördern
oder glauben sie dass mit diesem ansatz
den sie gerade auch versucht nochmal zu
erklären er jetzt das fördern nur noch
auf der tagesordnung steht bei ihnen in
der ampelkoalition
oder glauben sie auch immer noch dass
auch fordern auch wichtig ist in diesem
aspekt
kann den mein prinzip nennen ich möchte
menschen ermutigen und unterstützen aus
der situation herauszukommen
es wird bei mitwirkungspflichten bleiben
aber wenn sie eine formel haben wollen
hier so schön griffig ist dann würde ich
sagen diese fortschritts koalition wagt
mehr ermutigung und unterstützung um
menschen herauszuführen aus dem system
und das ist das was wir wollen wir
wollen dass menschen selbstbestimmt
leben können am arbeitsmarkt teilhaben
können weil arbeit für die meisten
menschen mehr ist als broterwerb ich
habe einen langzeitarbeitslosen menschen
kennengelernt in heidelberg der war 26
jahre arbeitslos nicht weil er voll war
sondern weil er ein schicksalsschlag
hatte der in psychischer aus der bahn
geschlossen hat
26 jahre er hat auf der straße gelebt
und er hat über den sozialen
arbeitsmarkt den wir ja gemeinsam
geschaffen haben jetzt eine arbeit
gefunden als hausmeister in einer
grundschule verdienen ist das leben
besser und anders und das ermutigt mich
diesen weg weiter zu gehen wir werden
übrigens einen sozialen arbeitsmarkt im
zuge der bürgergeld reformen der auf
druck der cdu ja nur befristet war
dauerhaft in fristen
nächste fragestellerin zum gleichen
thema die eine nachfrage hat annika
klose aus der spd fraktion
ja sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sagte
herr minister vielen herzlichen dank für
ihre ausführung zu diesem thema das
sanktionsmoratorium wozu gefragt wurde
ist ja der erste schritt hin zu unserem
zu unserer bürgergelds reform daher
möchte ich nachfragen welche priorität
messen sie denn der einführung des
bürgergeldes zu was ist dabei besonders
zu beachten und worauf kommt es
besonders an prognose ich danke für die
frage weil das auch die gelegenheit gibt
vielleicht den kollegen noch einmal zu
sagen wir führen kein bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen sondern ein soziales
bürgergeld an das ist das was wir machen
und ist eine große reform mit sehr sehr
großen elementen insgesamt hat der
koalitionsvertrag über 33 größere und
kleinere schritte zur
entbürokratisierung des systems zur
grundlegenden veränderung des
sozialstaates vorgelegt und deshalb hat
dieses thema für mich sehr sehr große
priorität
ich werde noch in diesem sommer dafür
einen gesetzentwurf vorlegen und wir
haben dann die gelegenheit in der
zweiten jahreshälfte im parlament wenn
das kabinett das beschließt es auch zu
debattieren und zu beschließen mir geht
es um folgendes wir müssen aus den
schützengräben der letzten 16 jahre in
der debatte um hartz 4 rauskommen wir
wollen hat es für überwinden und das ist
unser ziel miteinander weil feststellen
muss dass
das gesetz was da ist das sgb 200 sagen
uns alle praktiker wahrscheinlich eines
der bürokratischen gesetze ist dass es
gibt und das liegt nicht an den
fleißigen mitarbeiterinnen mitarbeiter
der jobcenter die übrigen hervorragende
arbeit machen aber die sagen wir aus der
praxis wir wollen menschen helfen wir
brauchen ein besseres gesetz erkennen
sich kleine sachen die man
entbürokratisieren kann von bescheiden
und vielem mehr und wir machen auch
größere elemente in dieser reform und
dafür zu sorgen dass der sozialstaat im
tun und im ton besser wird denn in der
korona zeit haben wir erlebt dass ganz
ganz viele menschen in die
grundsicherung kommen sie die nie
gedacht haben dass sie darauf angewiesen
sind und die haben das erlebt dass das
gut ist dass eine grundsicherung gibt
aber das ist zu bürokratisch ist das ist
auch eine konsequenz der letzten jahre
dass das vom kopf auf die füße stellen
und dass du aus dieser polarisierten
gesellschaftlichen debatte endlich raus
kommen mit einem zukunftsorientierten
sozialstaat der den menschen nicht vor
der nase steht sondern in diesem fall
von notlagen zur seite steht und ihn
möglichst hilft aus der situation wieder
herauszukommen das ist mein prinzip
insofern ja das hat hohe priorität für
den bundesarbeitsminister
können noch eine kurze nachfrage stellte
frau präsidentin das möchte ich gerne
tun
wenn wir über grundsicherung reden dann
gibt es noch ein zweites programm was
wir auflegen wollen das ist die
kindergrundsicherung mit dem sofort
zuschlag im gesetz zur sofort und einmal
zum einmal zuschlag haben wir bereits
einen ersten schritt dorthin getan sehr
geehrter herr minister wie bewerten sie
dieses vorhaben der koalition vor dem
hintergrund der insgesamt veränderten
rahmenbedingungen
kollegin das ist ein wichtiger
notwendiger schritt aber sie haben es
eben beschrieben es ist nur im vorgriff
auf das was wir eigentlich wollen
nämlich zusätzlich eine eigenständige
kindergrundsicherung in deutschland
einzuführen wir haben dazu verabredet
dass die federführung beim kinder sofort
zuschlag beim bundesarbeitsminister ist
die crew federführung bei der
bundesfamilienministerin
und das wird jetzt für die
kindergrundsicherung andersrum sein die
kollegin paus wird federführend sein wir
haben einen arbeits- zusammenhang
gegründet um in dieser legislaturperiode
eine kindergrundsicherung einzuführen
weil diese bundesregierung der
überzeugung ist dass kinder in der
grundsicherung eben keine kleinen
langzeitarbeitslosen sind sondern kinder
und jugendliche und deshalb material und
vor allen dingen der herr kollege
trainer hat das in der letzten debatte
wie ich finde sehr gut ausgeführt
bessere chancen auf ein selbstbestimmtes
leben führen soziale herkunft darf kein
dauerhaftes schicksal für kinder sein
jeder und jede muss die chance haben zu
einem selbstbestimmten leben zu kommen
das ist das prinzip dieser koalition bei
der einführung der kinder einzugehen
ich habe jetzt zum gleichen thema noch
drei fragestellerin und fragesteller die
würde ich jetzt auch noch dran nehmen
und alle haben ja auch die chance noch
eine nachfrage zu stellen aber dann
würde ich regulär wieder in diese frage
rein rangfolge gehen weil sonst kommen
wir in der stunde am ende nicht durch
dass alle fraktionen einmal auch eine
regulierung frage die angemeldet ist
stellen können ich meine sind alle
reguläre fragen entschuldigungen aber
aber sie wissen was ich meine jetzt habe
ich als nächstes die kollegin dr ottilie
klein aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentinnen lieber
herr bundesminister ich wollte noch mal
kurz auf das thema sanktionsmoratorium
zurückkommen es wurde jetzt ja auch
bereits deutlich dass sie sanktionen
aussetzen wollen für zwölf monate und da
würde mich interessieren ob sie dann
betroffenen nachträglich sanktionieren
wollen und falls nein wie sie diese form
der ungleichbehandlung begründen frau
kollegin vielleicht würde ich anregen
das ist ja im rahmen des bürgergeldes
auch möglich dass für den begriff
sanktionen weil weglassen und
fernwirkung mitwirkungspflichten und
leistungsminderung sprechen weil in
diesen zeiten sanktionen ein bisschen
anders belegt sind deshalb muss man mit
sprache vorsichtig sein kann ich meine
das ganze ernst
sie unterschätzen manchmal wenn sie das
unterschätzt wenn sie das schon
unterschätzen dann unterschätzen sie was
am tag politischen debatten bei
bürgerinnen und bürger manchmal ganz
anders ankommt also da müssen wir ein
bisschen aufpassen auch mit sprache aber
in der sache selbst finde ich das
beantworten
wir haben tatsächlich gesagt dass wir
zwölf monate das ist das was jetzt im
parlament verhandelt wird und hier
beschlossen werden soll das ist jetzt am
rand des parlamentarischen verfahrens
mitwirkungspflichten da sein sollen wie
wird es nach wie vor zu haben bei
meldeversäumnissen kann das auch in
wiederholten falle zu leistungsminderung
führen dass also keine vollständige
abschaffung der mitwirkungspflichten und
auch der rechtsfolgen an dieser stelle
und wir werden ein neues system auf
stellen sich das ihrem kollegen wurden
auch beschrieben haben mit dem
bürgergeld
sie dürfen eine nachfrage stellen
ich möchte meine frage nochmals
wiederholen
werden betroffener nach diesen zwölf
monaten nachträglich sanktioniert und
falls nein womit begründen sie diese
ungleichbehandlung frau kollegin ich
werde ein gesetzentwurf für das
bürgergeld vorliegen und das wird dann
ihre frage auch beantworten weil ich
kann jetzt dem gesetzgeber ja für das
was mit zukünftige gesetzgebung
stattfindet auch nicht vorgreifen aber
ich weiß was ich will
ja für das eine gesetzt das bürgergeld
kommt das wird ihre frage auch
beantworten aber ich sag mal
zukunftsfragen an dieser stelle kann ich
beantworten wenn der gesetzentwurf
vorliegt und dann glaube ich ist das
auch vernünftig wir haben eine einigung
für das sanktionsmoratorium sie es heißt
für dieses ein herr kollege ich habe
vorhin gesagt dass ja sie haben jetzt
nicht das wort glaube ich das teilte die
präsidentin aber die kollegin hatte
gefragt
das brauchen sie gar nicht ich wollte
die frage beantworten wir haben eine
einigung jetzt offensichtlich in der
koalition in diesem tag in diesen tagen
im bundestag debattiert oder auch
abgeschlossen wird wenn ich es richtig
war das gilt für die rechtslage dieses
einen jahres und für die frage wie es
dann weitergeht wird das bürgergeld
eingeführt und das wird ihre frage
beantworten
nächste nachfrage stellte der kollege
kleinwächter von der fdp fraktion
empfehlen eine frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister wir begleiten ja
mit großer aufmerksamkeit ihren
transformationsprozess hier und die
verwandlung von sanktionen in
mitwirkungspflichten und deswegen mal
die sehr klare frage an sie welchen
stellenwert hat danach rang grundsatz
den wir bislang in den sozialsystemen
hatten tatsächlich noch in ihrer
konzeption des bürgergeldes sie sprechen
ja eben nicht mehr von sanktionen wie
zum beispiel erfolgen wenn man eine
durchaus zu und bestelle nicht mehr
annimmt zu sprechen jetzt nur noch von
mitwirkungspflichten und das klingt
jetzt erstmal an erster stelle so gerade
auch weil sie ja die vermögensprüfung
ausgesetzt haben weil die sanktionen
ausgesetzt werden sollen weil sie zum
beispiel ukrainische flüchtlinge direkt
und sgb 2
einfügen nach einer deutlich gestiegenen
zahl an leistung
berechtigten aber auch an einer deutlich
ansteigenden zahl der sozialleistungen
also die höhe der sozialleistungen die
insgesamt ausgezahlt werden müssen was
sagen ihre kalkulationen da was kostet
ihre planung der steuerzahler zusätzlich
herr kollege
lorenzo menge fragen in ihrer frage ich
versuche einzel davon zu beantworten
habe ich schaff's nicht ganz in der
kürze der zeit das können wir glaube ich
noch debattieren zum einen will ich
ihnen erklären was damit gemeint ist es
für zwei jahre im bürgergeld dafür
sorgen werden dass die frage der größe
des wohnraums und auch ein nicht
erhebliches vermögen nicht angefasst
werden das haben wir der korona zeit
auch gemacht hintergrund ist dass wenn
menschen die grundsicherung kommen sie
sich nicht gleichzeitig noch um ihren
wohnraum gedanken und sorgen machen
müssen wir wollen dafür sorgen dass
menschen die in so eine existenzielle
not die grundsicherung kommen und das
ist immer eine existenzielle not sich
darauf konzentrieren können mit
unterstützung des staates wieder aus
dieser not zu kommen und sich nicht
gleichzeitig in zeiten von steigenden
mieten noch um wohnraum gedanken machen
zu müssen und ich finde das einen
richtigen weg das sollte zeitlich
begrenzt werden in der karenz aber das
ist das was die praktiker in den
jobcentern uns auch geraten haben dass
wir damit anders umgehen das zweite was
sie angesprochen haben zum thema der
ukrainischen geflüchteten habe ich
versucht ihn in der plenardebatte zum
sonderzuschlag auch schon mal zu
vermitteln das stimmt nicht was sie
sagen wir stellen die nicht besser wir
stellen sie gleich mit anerkannten
asylbewerbern weil die geflüchteten aus
der ukraine die auf putins krieg
geflohen sind hier nicht ein
asylverfahren durchlaufen wie andere
menschen die politisches asyl nachsuchen
und deshalb gar nicht aus dem
asylbewerberleistungsgesetz rauskommen
können das ist richtig und meine
herzliche bitte gerade an ihrer fraktion
in der ist eine große unterstützung für
ein putin gibt ist nicht die
geflüchteten an diesem punkt gegen die
einheimischen bedürftigen auszuspielen
das wäre unanständig und darum bitte ich
sie einfach ganz herzlich
sie dürfen eine nachfrage stellen er
wird der minister wir haben große
unterstützung für die deutschen
interessen aber nicht für putin meine
nachfrage gilt tatsächlich der ersten
frage die ich gestellt hatte demnach
rang grundsatz welchen stellenwert hat
der in ihren planungen also die tatsache
dass das sozialsystem nur für diejenigen
und zwar wirklich ausschließlich für
diejenigen zugänglich sein sollte die im
endeffekt keine möglichkeit haben ihren
lebensunterhalt selbst zu bestreiten
durch eine zumutbare stelle oder durch
vorhandenes vermögen es ist nachwievor
übrigens
nicht nur meine auffassung sondern
rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts in dem
einschlägigen urteil zur frage was
grundsicherung und dann auch bürgergeld
sein soll das ist ein nachrangiges
system dem grunde nach dass das sozio
kulturelle und sozioökonomische
existenzminimum von menschen die
sichtlich anders helfen kann abdecken
soll davor gibt es für viele
beschäftigte gott sei dank die
arbeitslosenversicherung die vielen
hilft nicht wenn sie arbeitslos werden
gleich in grundsicherung kommen zu
müssen ist ein system was starkes was
uns gerade in der kroner pandemie mit
kurzarbeit auch möglich gegeben hat
insofern ist das immer auch im
bürgergeld eine grundsicherung an der
existenz sichernde leistung die menschen
die sich sonst nicht helfen kann
weiterhelfen wird und ich glaube das
beantwortet ihre frage
die letzte nach fragerin ist jetzt aus
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen beate
müller-gemmeke
ja vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister ich möchte noch
einen anderen aspekt zum thema
bürgergeld ansprechen der haushalt 2023
steht ja vor den türen und in diesem
haushalt müssen wir natürlich alle
vorhaben der ampel auch abbilden und ein
zentrales vorhaben ist eben das
bürgergeld über das wir gerade hier
diskutieren wir wollen wir wollen
perspektivwechsel bei der
arbeitsförderung wir wollen beratung auf
augenhöhe wir wollen individuelle
angebote die zu den menschen passenden
fokus ist weiterbildung qualifizierung
wir wollen wirklich den menschen neue
chancen und perspektiven ermöglichen ich
wiederholt es nochmal auch in richtung
union weil es geht eben nicht nur um
sanktionen sondern es geht um den
perspektivwechsel den ländern mit dem
bürgergeld vorhaben für menschen die
sehr lange arbeitslos sind braucht es
vor allem soziale teilhabe und da geht
es um den sogenannten sozialen
arbeitsmarkt um den paragrafen 16 ehe
sie haben schon gesagt er wird
entfristet wir wollen auch ein bisschen
anders ausgestaltet meine frage ist
werden sie sich dafür einsetzen im
haushalt dass der soziale arbeitsmarkt
wirklich ausreichend finanziert wird und
damit meine ich besser als heute
frau kollegin die haushaltsaufstellung
22 der kann ich vorweg greifen die läuft
wir haben ja gerade jetzt glaube ich
bereinigungssitzung für meinen haushalt
donnerstag nacht zum 22 der haushalt wir
sind aber auch in der aufstellung
verfahren mit dem bundesfinanzminister
für 23 wenn sie mich nach meiner
fachlichen meinung fragen der soziale
arbeitsmarkt zeigt dass das richtig gut
investiertes geld ist wir haben über
50.000 menschen in
sozialversicherungspflichtige arbeit
nicht in irgendwelche maßnahmen gebracht
und es geht um menschen die ganz ganz
lange draußen sind und die trotz der
guten lage am arbeitsmarkt über viele
jahre von langzeitarbeitslosigkeit
sollte sonst keine chance hätten wieder
richtig in sozialversicherungspflichtige
arbeit zu kommen ich hab das vorhin am
beispiel eines menschen aus heidelberg
versucht zu beschreiben und das muss man
glaube ich in der arbeitsmarktpolitik
sehen die meisten menschen die
arbeitslos werden brauchen keine aktive
arbeitsmarktpolitik weil der
arbeitsmarkt ist es gibt welche die
brauchen aktive arbeitsmarktpolitik um
arbeitsplätze zu sichern stichwort
kurzarbeit aber menschen die 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 jahre arbeitslos sind die haben
meistens auch begleitende problem da
fehlt nicht nur arbeit und da müssen wir
brücken bauen und deshalb ja ich werde
mich dafür einsetzen dass wir den
arbeitsmarkt nicht nur in fristen
sondern möglichst auch die mittel
bekommen im eingliederungstitel dafür zu
sorgen dass wir den sozialen
arbeitsmarkt verstetigen und möglichst
auch ausbauen können um langzeit
arbeitslosigkeit wirksam zu bekämpfen
aber wir hätten eine nachfrage stellen
aber immer schon aber am ende entscheide
dieser bundestag über das geld soll das
ist ihr recht ist auch gut so genau
aber es ist auch gut so dass wir uns
alle zusammen irgendwie unterhaken und
auch wirklich für die richtigen aspekte
dann auch kämpfen im voraus wir haben
eine nachfrage geht dahin gehen dass ich
noch mal fragen will was denn darüber
hinaus noch zentrales wenzels bürgergeld
geht unser fokus liegt beispielsweise
ganz klar bei jungen menschen es geht
darum wirklich perspektiven zu eröffnen
ein wichtiges instrument ist
beispielsweise die assistierte
ausbildung
wo ich glaube dass wir sie stärken und
auch besser ausstatten müssen von daher
werde ich auch an der stelle noch mal
nachfragen werden sie sich mit uns
zusammen dafür einsetzen dass wir a dass
das instrument assistierte ausbildung
ein bisschen verändern und passgenauer
machen zum einen und dass wir aber auch
genügend finanzielle mittel für das
instrument assistierte ausbildung und
für ausbildung insgesamt für junge
menschen im sgb 2 haben aber kollegin
jahr ist die antwort aber das ist nicht
der wichtigste punkt es ist ganz zentral
dass für assistierte ausbildung für die
jungen leute auch besser organisieren
mehr organisieren die in das wirkliche
chance bringt wirklich wieder in
ausbildung zu bekommen aber das größere
bild ist und das kann ich glaube ich an
dieser stelle sagen dass man ist die
struktur der langzeitarbeitslosigkeit in
deutschland mal genauer angucken muss
leute die sich nicht mit
arbeitsmarktpolitik beschäftigen die
stehen ja vor einem rätsel das da heißt
der arbeitsmarkt ist super aber wir
haben trotzdem noch so ein verfestigten
sockel von langzeitarbeitslosigkeit wie
passt das eigentlich zusammen sind hier
alle zu faul oder was es los das ist die
unterstellung die manchmal mitschwingt
das ist gesellschaftliches gift und
deshalb muss man sich die realität
angucken und die realität sagt dass zwei
drittel der langzeitarbeitslosen
menschen keine abgeschlossene
berufsausbildung haben und das jahr für
jahr 50.000 junge menschen die schule
verlassen ohne schulabschluss und wir in
zeiten des fachkräftemangels 1,3
millionen menschen zwischen 20 und 30
ohne berufsausbildung in deutschland
haben und denen müssen wir eine zweite
eine dritte chance geben am besten ist
es übrigens der entwicklung den
nachwuchs abzugraben und deshalb ist ein
element was sich zusätzlich zur
assistierten ausbildung kurz erwähnen
will die tatsache dass wir mit dem
vermittlungs vorrang im sgb 2 anders
umgehen werden moment steht im gesetz
man muss die leute in irgendwelche
arbeit bringen übersetzt das mal das
führt dazu dass viele ohne ausbildung
mal kurz in arbeit kommen manchmal auch
in prekärer arbeiten das jobcenter die
dann wieder sieht das ist keine
nachhaltige integration arbeitsmarkt mit
dem bürgergeld werden wir einführen das
sind zweifelsfall das nachholen eines
berufsabschlusses vorrang hat vor der
vermittlung in irgendwelche arbeit also
wenn sie so wollen ordentliche arbeit
statt hilfskräfte zu produzieren das ist
übrigens auch gut für die
fachkräftesicherung in diesem land
ich gehe jetzt wieder über in die liste
der angemeldeten
fragestellerin und fragesteller und
erzählen nächstes ist andreas andreades
strand von der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
sehr geehrter herr minister wir haben
große transformationen vor uns in dieser
gesellschaft das bezieht sich auf die
digitalisierung bezieht sich natürlich
auch auf den demografischen wandel aber
ganz besonders auch darauf dass wir
unsere wirtschaft klimaneutral gestalten
wollen und wir haben eine ganze menge an
instrumenten im koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart eine ganze weiterbildungs
strategie von lebenschancen bafög über
die weiterentwicklung auch in anlehnung
an das kurzarbeitergeld zum
qualifizierungs geld und da würde ich
sie gerne fragen was ist ihre
perspektive zeitlich und wie würden sie
diese instrumente einordnen und
vielleicht auch in dem zusammenhang die
b a plant weiterbildungs verbünde um
regional agieren zu können wie sehen sie
das in dem konzept dessen was wir im
koalitionsvertrag insgesamt vereinbart
hatten lieber kollege autos ganz
herzlichen dank wollen wir das wirklich
ein großes anliegen ist neben dem
aktuellen krisen management macht die
transformation die geprägt ist durch
digitalisierung dekarbonisierung und
demographie am arbeitsmarkt gar keinen
halt im gegenteil es gibt bestimmte
sachen die schneller gehen werden das
haben ein crooner bei der
digitalisierung erlebt und das erleben
wir jetzt auch bei der notwendigkeit
unabhängiger von fossilen importen zu
werden und das hat folgen für den
arbeitsmarkt und wenn wir wollen dass
die beschäftigten von heute die chance
haben die arbeit von morgen zu machen
und wenn wir uns vergegenwärtigen dass
2030 die arbeitskräfte dann mehrheitlich
am arbeitsmarkt tätig sind ihre
ausbildung übrigens meistens schon
hinter sich haben dann kommen wir zum
thema qualifizierung und weiterbildung
wir haben eine nationale weiterbildung
strategie die federführend von der
bundesbildungsministerin
und von mir betreut wird und wir werden
dafür sorgen dass es neue instrumente
gibt da bin ich sehr froh dass der
koalitionsvertrag viele gute neue
instrumente zum beispiel die einführung
der bildungszeit nach österreichischem
vorbild das heißt der bildungskarenz und
es gibt menschen die chance tatsächlich
auch ihre arbeit unterbrechen zu können
wenn es eine vereinbarung mit den
arbeitgebern gibt und sich beruflich
weiterzubilden und dabei den
lebensstandard auch gesichert zu
bekommen das hat in österreich dazu
geführt dass die weiterbildung gepustet
wurde im bereich der betrieb der
beruflichen weiterbildung sie haben
instrumente wie das lebenschancen war
fügt das ist unter federführung der
kollegin stark watzinger die ich sehr
interessant finde wir haben das
instrument beispielsweise für einen
transformationsprozess zu sorgen wenn
unternehmen mehr in weiterbildung
investieren das habe ich in der letzten
legislaturperiode mit dem arbeit von
morgen gesetz durchgesetzt und wir
werden ein führen analog zu der idee des
transformation school ist die stärkere
verbindung von kurzarbeit mit
qualifizierung
warum sage ich das so ausführlich weil
für den transformationsländern den wir
haben
frau präsidentin wir nicht nur einen
schraubenschlüssel brauchen wir brauchen
einen ganzen werkzeugkasten dafür damit
die beschäftigten von heute die chance
haben die arbeit von morgen zu machen
daran arbeite ich mit hochdruck ich
rechne mit gesetzgebung fürs nächste
jahr
sie dürfen eine nachfrage stellen und
der minister antwortete nicht etwas
kürzer der minister hat quasi die zeit
für zwei fragen verwendet insofern es in
ordnung
vielen dank ich habe jetzt gerade
gesehen zum gleichen thema zwei
nachfragen aus der cdu/csu-fraktion ich
würde die zwei zu lassen und dann gerne
wieder übergehen wenn jetzt nichts
dagegen spricht in die nächste
reihenfolge weil wir sonst in der stunde
mit den fraktionen sonst nicht
durchkommen sie haben das wort kollegen
sie haben jetzt beschrieben was sie tun
wollen im nächsten jahr natürlich frage
ich mich was haben sie schon getan denn
in bezug auf weiterbildung haben wir
eine ganz akute situation wir haben die
zuwanderung von geflüchteten menschen
die kommen mit qualifikationen sie
kommen aber häufig ohne sprachkenntnisse
und der wird frage ich sehe was haben
sie getan um die anerkennung von
abschlüssen von ukrainischen
flüchtlingen zu verbessern
welche qualifizierungsmaßnahmen haben
sie auf den weg gebracht um diese ohne
job zu qualifizieren und was tun sie
dagegen dass diese geflüchteten nicht in
geringqualifizierter tätigkeit landen
weil sie ja meistens dringend geld
brauchen ganz herzlichen dank frau
kollegin das kann ich ihnen sagen wir
haben als allererstes dafür gesorgt
nachdem das dafür gesorgt wurde dass die
menschen ihren schutzstatus bekommen und
sie gleichzeitig übrigens eine
arbeitserlaubnis bekommen dass es dass
wir die sprachkurse für sie geöffnet
haben das betrifft die sprachkurse des
bamf im bereich von nancy faeser und die
auch arbeitsmarkt bezogen sprachkurse in
meinem verantwortungsbereich und ich bin
zuversichtlich dass wir am im neuen
haushalt im ergänzung des haushalts 22
dafür auch noch zusätzliche mittel von
ihnen bekommen können zweitens werden
gestern eine weitere schalter einer task
force die besteht aus frau stark
watzinger und mir also bildungs in
arbeitslohn ist damit karl josef laumann
dem arbeitsminister von nordrhein
westfalen und dem für die
kultusministerkonferenz
ties rabe in hamburg der ist der
bildungssenator um ganz konkret die
berufsanerkennung voranzutreiben sowohl
für die geschützten berufe als auch für
die nicht geschützten beruf weil sie
haben vollkommen recht die menschen aus
der ukraine die jetzt zu uns flüchten
haben wir im schnitt im schnitt ein sehr
hohes ausbildungsniveau und wir müssen
ohnehin besser werden als in der
vergangenheit in der berufsanerkennung
damit die nicht alle zu hilfskräften
gemacht werden und das ist das was wir
tun und das ist schon eine gute übung
für die erweiterung des fachkräfte eines
gesetzes für das wir dass ohnehin
brauchen ich bin froh dass das in dieser
koalition besser gelingt als der
vorgänger regierung bedienen
sie dürfen alle nach vorgestellt ja das
war jetzt noch mal eine kleine stichelei
so gute entscheidung von ihnen dass sie
karl josef laumann einbinden in diesem
prozess dann sind wir haben das als
gutes auskommen
ich möchte sie doch noch mal an meine
frage erinnern weil die erfahrung auch
aus den vorangegangenen
zuwanderungs geschehen zeigt dass die
leute mit sprachkursen erstmal nicht
viel anfangen können weil sie dann zwei
drei jahre brauchen bis sie die sprache
erlernt haben und dann sagt man ihnen
jetzt kannst du mal anfangen sich zu
qualifizieren noch mal zwei jahre und
dann darfst du in den job gehen das
heißt wir brauchen doch und da frage ich
sie was haben sie da schon getan wir
brauchen doch maßnahmen um die leute on
the job zu qualifizieren und ihnen
sprache gleichzeitig zu vermitteln ich
weiß viele arbeitgeber wären dazu auch
bereit was haben sie getan herr minister
um solche maßnahmen auf den weg zu
bringen die wir jetzt dringend brauchen
bestehende maßnahmen frau kollegin
aktiviert gerade für diesen bereich ich
konnte mich gestern bei der bahn ag ich
habe das vorher geschrieben
davon in kenntnis setzen dass der
wirtschaft und bundesagentur für arbeit
mit den instrumenten die wir haben gut
zusammen arbeiten will ich sehr
unbürokratisch und ich habe am beispiel
dieser beiden frauen von denen ich
vorhin gesprochen habe erlebt dass wir
beides machen die konnten beide noch
nicht richtig gut deutsch die finden
jetzt aber einen job und sie kriegen
unterstützung auch durch die
bundesagentur für arbeit training on the
job die sprache dabei zu erlernen sie
haben vollkommen recht wir dürfen keine
zeit verlieren und die frage warum karl
josef laumann dabei ist nicht nur weil
er kenntnis hat sondern weil er gerade
vorsitzende der arbeits und
sozialministerkonferenz ist und ich kann
das nicht ohne länder hinbekommen bei
der verstreuung der kompetenzen im
bereich von beruf anerkennung zwischen
bund und ländern da haben sie die
geschützten beruf oft in länderkompetenz
da haben sie sozialen beruf in
länderkompetenz da sie die berufliche
bildung in bundeskompetenz da haben sie
im übrigen die akademische bildung auch
noch da haben sie 1400 stellen in
deutschland die für beruf seiner canon
zuständig ist und ich will dass wir das
schnell hinbekommen und das geht nur
gemeinsam mit auch parteiübergreifend
deshalb danke ich ihnen auch für das
interesse und die engagement in diesem
thema das unterstützt die politik der
bundesregierung
zum gleichen thema hat noch eine
nachfrage dr reichelt
cdu/csu-fraktion
minister sie haben in ihren einführungen
verwiesen auf die auf die weiterbildungs
strategie in der sie auch auf die
hervorragenden abstimmung mit dem bmbf
verwiesen haben ein teil dieser
weiterbildungs strategie ist ist die
erstellung eines entsprechenden portals
für weiterbildungsplattform nun hat die
hochschulrektorenkonferenz in abstimmung
mit dem bmbf gerade im april ein eigenes
eine eigene plattform in gang genommen
hoch und weit heißt die gleichzeitig ist
im haushalt des bms mit 18 millionen
euro sehr große mittel eingestellt für
die erstellung der nationalen
weiterbildungsplattform die über die
berufs agentur entsprechend
betrieben werden soll meine frage ist
nun in welcher form bestimmen denn diese
beiden plattformen sich ab was ist der
vorteil dieser doppelstruktur und
inwieweit vermeiden sie ihren
effizienten ganz herzlichen dank für
diese frage weil das habe ich bereits
würde ich die rate der acht letzten
regierung auch schon angehört als
diskussion mit der kollegin damaligen
bundesbildungsministerin frau
carlitscheck wie sie das auch fragen
kann glaube ich auch besprochen es ist
richtig dass wir beides aufbauen aber
dass wir das nicht als sozusagen
unabhängige röhren haben sondern dass
für das gute miteinander vernetzen und
verlinken es ist richtig dass die
bundesagentur im aufbau ein bisschen
weiter ist nach dem was ich weiß als die
plattform die sie beschrieben haben aber
beides wird vor allen dingen vereins
sorgen dass die passgenauen
weiterbildungsangebot die es in
deutschland sehr vielfältig gibt
transparenter werden für die menschen
die es brauchen das werden wir gut
miteinander verbinden und deshalb ist
das kein widerspruch sondern ist die
gesamte bandbreite die wir abdecken wir
haben doch in deutschen das problem dass
zu viele beschäftigten die tatsächlich
vorhandenen weiterbildungsangebote sehr
sehr sehr unübersichtlich sind übrigens
genauso unübersichtlich wie die vielzahl
von berufsbildern die in deutschland
haben und deshalb ist es vernünftig dass
wir digitale systeme schaffen dann wird
menschen passgenaue angebote machen und
das machen wir gemeinsam in der
fortschreibung der nationalen
weiterbildungs strategie die wir mit dem
bundesbildungsministerium abstimmen
werden werden sie das auch noch machen
die letzte nationale bildungsstrategie
habe ich mit anja karliczek mit den
sozialpartnern auch der wissenschaft
aufgestellt die nächste wird jetzt vor
ort geschrieben mit der neuen kollegin
und sie wird ambitionierter sein
sie dürfen eine nachfrage stellt
da möchte ich doch natürlich noch mal
nachfragen sie haben zu recht darauf
hingewiesen dass der seit jahren sei die
man markt für weiterbildung
unübersichtlich ist wir haben sie aber
jetzt nicht erklärt inwieweit sie zu der
übersichtlichkeit beitragen indem die
bundesregierung nun anstelle von einer
einzigen weiterbildungsplattform nun
zwei parallel erstellen will wo ist hier
exakt die abgrenzung dann herr kollege
habe ich eben nicht deutlich genug
formuliert was ich sagen wollte da bitte
ich um entschuldigung es geht um zwar
unterschiedliche segmente und wir werden
dafür sorgen dass diese dinge
miteinander vernetzt sind die simple
vorstellung die in ihrer fraktion mal da
war mannschaft mal so ein netflix die
gibt es halt nicht an dieser stelle
sondern wir unterschiedliche segmente
und ansätze weil wir auch
unterschiedliche zielgruppen haben aber
wir werden dafür sorgen dass diese
beiden systeme nicht sozusagen
digital sich auseinanderentwickelt
sondern gut miteinander verzahnt werden
und das ist glaube ich ein guter schritt
aber ich kann in der kürze der zeit
ihnen das ausführlicher möglicherweise
auch schriftlich oder in einem gespräch
auf dem kaffee wenn sie den kaffee
zahlen gerne auch erläutern
ich muss ja die haushaltsmittel des
hauses sparen bei uns ja
vielen dank wir
gehen weiter in der liste der
angemeldeten fragesteller und der
nächste ist rené springer aus der fdp
fraktion
vielen dank frau präsidentin herr
minister zunächst möchte ich kritik üben
denn es wurde jetzt zweifach wurden
problembereiche angesprochen die von
ungerechtigkeiten geprägt sind und ihre
reaktionen war jeweils man sollte nicht
gruppen gegeneinander ausspielen
ich denke dass das ein totschlagargument
ist und dass das ein versuch ist eine
debatte abzuwürgen aber das hier ist ein
haus in dem eine debatte geführt werden
muss auch wenn es manchmal unangenehm
ist und deswegen kritisiere ich sie
dafür dass sie hier versuchen debatte
abzuwürgen zu meiner frage laut aussagen
zahlen ihres ministeriums haben zuletzt
mütter die drei kinder zur welt gebracht
haben einen durchschnittlichen renten
zahlbetrag von 751 euro im monat gehabt
eine hartz 4 empfänger sagen wir hier in
berlin hat einen regelsatz anspruch von
449 euro hinzukommen 426 euro richtwert
für kosten der unterkunft macht 880 euro
eine frau die also drei kinder zur welt
gebracht hat ihre lebensleistung
erbracht hat erhält 130 euro weniger als
eine person die unter umständen noch nie
einen cent ins sozialsystem eingezahlt
hat jetzt haben sie ein entlastungspaket
eingebracht das beschlossen wurde das
200 euro für hartz-iv-empfänger vorsieht
rentner gehen leer aus wir als fdp
fraktion verurteilen sie ganz klar dafür
dass die rentner hieraus lassen
ignorieren fallen lassen wir werden
einen antrag einbringen der iss
vorbereitet wo wir 300 euro für rentner
fordern dass nämlich der betrag den
arbeitnehmer als etwas druck gehalten
meine frage ist können sie sich dieser
forderung in der sache anschließen
sehr geehrter herr kollege springer das
ist ein freies land und hier kann jeder
im parlament meinung vertreten aber sie
müssen auch damit rechnen dass ihnen
widersprochen wird und deshalb bleibe
ich bei der haltung der bundesregierung
wir werden menschen in not die aus
unterschiedlichen gründen aber gemeinsam
in not sind in dieser gesellschaft nicht
gegeneinander ausspielen das will ich
ihnen auch zu dieser frage sagen
will ich ihn auch zu ihrer frage sagen
weil der hintergrund ist doch klar warum
haben menschen im alter niedrige renten
und die antwort ist klar
armut im alter der armutsgefährdung im
alter ist meistens das ergebnis von
armut im erwerbsverlauf das heißt von
langzeitarbeitslosigkeit zum beispiel
von viel zu niedrigen renten die
aufgrund von viel zu schlechte bezahlung
da war deshalb führen wir beispielsweise
den mindestlohn ein weil das vor allen
dingen brigens frauen helfen wird an
dieser stelle und zu ihrem bemerken der
entlastungspaket möchte ich sie auf die
debatte verweisen wir können gerne
darüber unterhalten ob genug für
rentnerinnen und rentner dabei war kann
man unterschiedlicher meinung sein aber
ihre behauptung dass in den
leistungspaket nichts für rentnerinnen
und rentner dabei ist es schlichtweg
falsch das will ich ihnen kurz sagen da
gibt es allgemeine maßnahmen von denen
auch rentnerinnen ränder profitiert
haben die abschaffung der eeg-umlage ist
teil des leistungspakets da gehört der
heizkostenzuschuss dazu für wohngeld im
verein zudem zu 50 prozent renten und
rentner profitieren werden die zuschüsse
für die rentnerinnen und rentner in der
grundsicherung im alter will ich gar
nicht erwähnen deshalb nochmal ihre
debatte ob das genug ist die kann man
gerne führen auch mit mir und ich sage
auch sehr deutlich das was du jetzt eine
entlastungspaket machen hilft das leben
für viele ein bisschen einfacher zu
machen und wird von 30 milliarden euro
und wenn wir dauerhaft preissteigerung
haben werden wir auch weitere
strukturelle maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
aber ihre behauptung das nächste rentner
drin auch wenn sie sie zehnmal
wiederholen ist schlicht wahrheitswidrig
und das müssen sie sich gefallen lassen
im übrigen sie können mich politisch
verurteilen rechtlich können sie es
nicht
die liefern minister und auch jetzt die
dürfen die nachfrage stellen aber ist
jetzt fast eine minute über sogar bitte
die antwort kurz sondern auch die
fragestellung kürzer herr minister ich
habe eine ganz konkrete frage gestellt
hartz4 empfänger bekommen 200 euro mehr
arbeitnehmer bekommt 200 euro mehr
kinder bekommen ja nur rentner bekommen
keinen einmal zuschlag noch mal die
frage schließen sie sich in der sache
einer forderung der afg an 300 euro
einmal zuschlag an rentner so wie sie es
bei arbeitnehmern getan haben sie haben
glaube ich von an dieser stelle habe ich
gesagt in der grundsicherung im alter
und davon habe ich gesprochen kriegen
rentnerinnen und rentner in der
grundsicherung im alter genauso die 200
euro zuschlag wie die in anderen grund
sicherungssysteme aus insofern werden
renten in der grundsicherung nicht
anders behandelt als andere menschen in
der grundsicherung und ich habe vorhin
beschrieben welche weiteren
entlastungsmaßnahmen wir haben insofern
glaube ich ist die erste frage
beantwortet gewesen und zwar ziemlich
präzise herr kollege
ich lasse jetzt auch wieder zwei
nachfragen zu diesem thema zu und dann
gehe ich weiter weil wir sind in der
zeit fortgeschritten sonst komme ich
nicht durch die liste der fragestellerin
nächste frage stellt aus der
fdp-fraktion frau geriet hui
dank dass sich nachfragen darf herr
minister sie haben darauf hingewiesen
dass niedrige renten die ursache oder
zur sache haben niedrige löhne das ist
im prinzip auch sehr korrekt sie müssen
sich aber trotzdem vorwerfen lassen dass
auch niedrige einkommensbezieher in
anderen ländern eine weit höhere rente
trotzdem haben weil eben das
rentenniveau gerade für die
niedriglöhner in den meisten anderen
ländern erhöht ist und über dem liegt
sie haben es ein bisschen kompensiert
für 1,3 millionen grund rentenempfänger
die kriegen eine gewisse verbesserung
aber wir haben viel mehr arme rentner
und für die muss auch was getan werden
danke
frau kollegin sie werden erstaunt sein
aber ich bin ihrer meinung dass wir viel
viel mehr tun müssten um altersarmut in
deutschland zu bekämpfen und zu
vermeiden wir haben erste schritte
gemacht und sie sehen danke dass sie die
grundrente gelobt haben die hilft
nämlich sehr vielen menschen wir werden
als regierung übrigens über das
vorgeschlagen in kürze glaube ich in
diesem bundestag beschließen dass wir
bei den erwerbsgeminderten leistungen
verbessern das sind rentnerinnen und
rentner die ihr lebtag gearbeitet haben
aber die aufgrund von erkrankung von
behinderung oder arbeitsunfällen
tatsächlich niedrige leistung haben im
alter und das ist jetzt endlich gelingt
und das ist überfällig das gebe ich zu
das war in der letzten regierung nicht
möglich aber in dieser regierung ist es
möglich bei den erwerbsgeminderten im
bestand zu verbesserungen zu kommen das
ist so also ich sag ihnen
erstaunlicherweise wir haben eine
ähnliche analyse der lage wir haben
unterschiedliche instrumente über die
wir streiten können an dieser stelle
aber das ist ein thema was mich sehr
bewegt aber ich bleib bei dem prinzip
das was im erwerbsleben schief geht
aufgrund von viel zu niedrigen löhnen
oder tags oder unterbrechungen von
erwerbstätigkeit das schlägt sich im
alter nieder dann auch in niedrigen
renten und da müssen wir an die wurzel
run durch gleichstellung von männern und
frauen am arbeitsmarkt beispielsweise
durch anständige löhne auch für soziale
berufe da ist der mindestlohn ein
wichtiger schritt aber das beste ist
ordentliche tarifverträge diesen bereich
und dafür werden wir auch kämpfen
sie dürfen an den nachwuchs bei richtung
ja vielen dank also ich kenne die
maßnahme und begrüßte sie auch aber ich
möchte trotzdem hat noch mal darauf
hinweisen dass ist weiter bei vielen
millionen armen rentner bleibt das liegt
an unseren jährigen rentenniveau und
bisher auch an der unfähigkeit der
vergangenen regierungen für
geringverdiener dieses rentenniveau zu
erhöhen und meine frage ganz konkret
haben sie das noch vor also erstens
werden wir vor allen dingen in dieser
region dafür sorgen dass das bestehende
rentenniveau dauerhaft gesichert wird
und das ist angesichts der demografie
schon eine sehr heftige aufgabe weil ab
2025 sehr geburtenstarke jahrgänge das
sind die die von 1964 geboren sind in
großer zahl in wohlverdiente rente gehen
werden davon sind nicht alle arm es gibt
auch anderen rentner mit einer
ordentlichen absicherung aber wir haben
der rentnerin rentner und das ist der
größte teil der nicht in saus und braus
lebt und einige sind armutsgefährdet
und deshalb so bleibe ich dabei die
sicherung des rentenniveaus ist eine
große aufgabe und ich bin froh dass
diese regierung sich das vorgenommen hat
dass wir das rentenniveau auch über 2025
hinaus dauerhaft sichern wollen das ist
das was wir tun die
nächste nachfrage stellt max straubinger
cdu csu fraktion
herr bundesminister sie an der zu recht
darauf hingewiesen die renten sind
unterschiedlich und sie sind ja
letztendlich nachvollzogen des
erwerbslebens und auch damit der
verbundenen beitragszahlung das bedeutet
aber dann auch bei rentner wenn man das
entlastungs paket der bundesregierung
betrachtet gerade bei den heizkosten
zuschlag der ja gebunden ist an die
sozialversicherungspflichtige
beschäftigung
müsste dann nicht daraus folgerichtig
hier die folgerung erfolgen dass damit
auch die rentnerinnen und rentner
genauso entlastet werden müssten ist wie
die die in
sozialversicherungspflichtiger
beschäftigung sind weil es ja einen
inneren zusammenhang gibt zwischen der
vorhergehenden
sozialversicherungspflichtigen
beschäftigung und ich würde die ist
damit als er schon untermauern dass den
rentnerinnen und rentnern diese 300 euro
zustehen lieber herr kollege den
heizkostenzuschuss den sie angesprochen
haben den kriegen alle wohngeld
empfängerin und wohngeldempfänger oder
sind zu 50 prozent rentnerinnen und
rentner der heizkostenzuschuss den sie
angesprochen haben ist nicht eine
erwerbstätigkeit sondern einen bezug von
wohngeld gekoppelt und das kriegen alle
die wohngeld bedürfen in deutschland und
noch mal dass ein zu 50 prozent drin im
rentner und deshalb ist es falsch dass
die retterin rentner nicht vom
heizkostenzuschuss den sie angesprochen
haben profitieren
sie dürfen eine nachfrage stellen
eine zweite frage
weil er diese auch immer dargelegt wird
von der rente dass sie so niedrig sind
oder die durchschnittsrenten zu niedrig
sind würde dies bedeuten nach jeder
aussage nach dass sie eine abkehr wollen
vom äquivalenzprinzip
in der rentenversicherung
herr kollege das äquivalenzprinzip gilt
aber wir haben wenn wir es genauer
betrachten auch abweichung jetzt schon
im system
beispielsweise in dem was hier ihre
partei mit unserer gemeinsam beschlossen
haben und andrea nahles hat es dann
umgesetzt endlich auch verbesserungen
bei der mutter rente beschlossen das
entspricht nicht ganz einem
äquivalenzprinzip was eine zahlung
betrifft aber es ist sozialpolitisch
richtig dass die rente das macht das
betrifft auch die einführung der
grundrente weil wir über fleißige
menschen vor allem frauen reden das
haben wir auch gemeinsam beschlossen den
lebt gearbeitet haben aber die viel zu
niedrige löhne hatten das ist nicht die
reine lehre des äquivalenzprinzip aber
das ist die solidarität der
rentenversicherung die in ordnung ist
aber ich bleibe beim äquivalenzprinzip
nur ihre frage ist nur berechtigt ob die
durchschnittsbetrachtung der
gesetzlichen rente allein schon ein
genaues bild macht und das macht es
nicht wir haben ich habe es vorhin
beschrieben menschen die sind in
altersarmut oder armutsgefährdet wir
haben menschen die haben eine mittlere
rente die ist nicht in saus und braus
und wir haben leute haben ganz
ordentlich altersabsicherung wenn man
alles zusammen macht und der medialen
dieser betrachtung kann ein bisschen
verzerren weil es auch leute gibt die
zum beispiel mal kurz die
rentenversicherung einbezahlt haben und
dann bei amt sind beamte geworden sind
und dann zeigt sich irgendwie dass in
der statistik sie nur ganz niedrige
rentenanwartschaften haben und das sieht
dann für alle wie niedriger durchschnitt
aus ich glaube wir haben gemeinsam die
aufgabe für mehr transparenz zu sorgen
was den menschen zusteht ohne
irgendetwas zu beschönigen am deutschen
system aber wir sollten vor allem eins
tun herr straubinger betrachten dass die
gesetzliche rente die tragende säule der
alterssicherung bleibt und dafür werde
ich arbeiten
ich gehe jetzt wieder über in die liste
der fragesteller und da habe ich als
nächste für die spd-fraktion rascher
nasa als fragesteller
vielen dank frau präsidentin werther
minister heil sie haben in ihren
einleitenden worten
und gedanken als parlamentarierin für
die konstruktive zusammenarbeit deswegen
möchte ich gerne im namen der
spd-fraktion weil wir eben so große
themen auf dem tableau haben diesen dank
zurück geben an sie und das bmf vielen
dank für die konstruktive zusammenarbeit
sie haben ja schon davon gesprochen den
schnellen wechsel von ukrainerin ins sgb
2 haben wir hier vollzogen ich würde
gerne noch mal den blick auf den bereich
arbeitsmarkt integration etwas breiter
lenken wir stehen vor großen
herausforderungen vor setzen sie die
prioritäten im bhs was ist jetzt noch zu
tun
aber kollegen ganz herzlichen dank für
die frage wie haben erfolgen glaube ich
und es gibt da kaum unterschiedlichen
diesem bundestag parteiübergreifend
festgestellt dass das thema der
fachkräftesicherung
eine entscheidende frage nicht nur für
den sozialen zusammenhalt dieser
gesellschaft ist sondern für die
wirtschaftliche zukunft des landes denn
fachkräfte klemmen die wir jetzt schon
in einzelnen bereichen haben drohen zu
einer dauerhaften wachstumsbremse zu
werden und dafür ist im sinne der
integration notwendig alle inländischen
potenziale die wir zu haben eben eine
höhere frauenerwerbsquote einigung
beispielsweise dafür zu sorgen dass
langzeitarbeitslose wieder in arbeit
kommen dass menschen ohne
berufsabschluss den nachholen können
dass jeder junge mensch durch eine
ordentliche ausbildung einen einstieg
ins arbeitsleben bekommen mit der
ausbildungsgarantie die wir organisieren
wollen das thema weiterbildung das alles
werden wir alle register ziehen für
fachkräftesicherung und gleichwohl
brauchen wir ergänzende fachkräfte
einwanderung aus dem ausland ich war
froh dass ich in der letzten
legislaturperiode mit dem kollegen
seehofer einen ersten schritt mit dem
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz machen
konnte und werte gedacht dass horst
seehofer und ich das schon mal gemeinsam
zustande bringen aber wir müssen
weitergehen das hat sich diese koalition
vorgenommen wir werden das
einwanderungsgesetz grundlegend erneuern
wir werden gezielt dafür sorgen dass für
kluge köpfe und helfende hände in
deutschland bekommen und wir müssen mit
denen auch besser umgehen die aus
anderen gründen aus humanitären gründen
ihr aufnahme gefunden haben die aber
sehr lange geblieben sind
die mittlerweile auch zugang zum
arbeitsmarkt gefunden haben und deshalb
war die beschäftigungs duldung schon ein
wichtiger schritt bei mir viele
handwerksmeister aus süddeutschland
voran den gesagt haben heute schiebt
nicht die falschen abdi können wir gut
gebrauchen
und ich finde das ist ein vernünftiger
geist und den werden wir weiter auch in
dieser regierung fortsetzen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass sie in zeiten der
demografie haben arbeitsmarkt alle
inländischen potenziale hessen und die
leute die wir noch gebrauchen können
auch in anderen ländern dazu bewegen
möglichst nach deutschland zu kommen um
hier zu leben zu arbeiten und wir werden
einen fehler der vergangenheit vorne
soll ich weiß dass sie sich dafür sehr
interessieren nicht machen wir werden
beachten da kommen die ich nur
arbeitskräfte sondern es kommen menschen
das heißt wir müssen integration dann
auch mit linken
herr minister ich höre ihn wirklich
gerne zu aber es ist sehr lang
schuldigen es soll ein wundes
übergelaufen ist klar dass gehören auch
dazu dass es nicht
sie haben sich hingesetzt keine
nachfrage gut dann habe ich zwei ich
lasse nur zwei nachfragen zuwider wie
gerade eben weil wir immer noch zwei
fraktionen haben die noch nicht
rangekommen sind in der frage als erster
norbert kleinwächter fdp-fraktion
werde werde frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister sie haben gerade
gesagt sie wollen alle hebel ziehen bei
der fachkräftesicherung und haben viel
gesprochen über frauen
erwerbsbeteiligung sie haben gesprochen
über integration über migration sie
haben aber einen aspekt ausgelassen und
das sind die über 100.000 fachkräfte die
fleißigen hände die durchaus
intelligenten personen die unser land
jedes jahr verlassen und sie tun das zum
teil wegen einer sehr hohen belastung
mit steuern und sozialabgaben sie tun
das zum teil weil sie die veränderungen
die diese bundesregierung aber auch die
vorgänger bundesregierung unter ihrer
beteiligung in diesem land erreicht
haben ihnen zutiefst missfallen oder
auch die geldpolitik was sagen sie oder
welche hebel wollen sie denn ziehen zur
sicherung der bereits vorhandenen
fachkräfte die im begriff sind unser
land zu verlassen
herr kollege demographie ist tatsächlich
wenn man das entschlüsselt bestandteil
aus lebenserwartung geburtenrate und zu
und abwanderung das macht dennoch die
demografie am arbeitsmarkt prägenden
übrigens auch die renten an dieser
stelle ich glaube dass deutschland für
fachkräfte durchaus ein attraktives land
ist übrigens auch für leute die sehr
viel verdienen ich kenne viele davon die
übrigens in diesem land gerne sind und
steuern zahlen weil unsere infrastruktur
im vergleich zu anderen ländern die
manchmal viel niedrigere steuern haben
dann doch manchmal besser ist als in
teilen amerikas
die zweite nachfolge stellt der kollege
karl josef cronenberg
vielen dank frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister vielen dank dass
sie die fachkräftesicherung hier
ansprechen in der tat eine der ganz
großen herausforderungen für die
wirtschaft in vielen regionen und
branchen haben wir arbeitskräfte und
fachkräftemangel
die koalition hat sich da so einiges
vorgenommen unter anderem die
entfristung der westbalkan regelung ich
höre allerdings aus der praxis dass es
da immer wieder wegen komplizierter
terminvergaben und auch wegen den der
kontingentierung der sehr streng zu
problemen kommt so dass die fachkräfte
erst viele monate später tatsächlich und
den ziel deutschland antreten können
daher meine frage kann das wie immer es
diesen eindruck bestätigen und wenn ja
ist dass birma es im austausch mit dem
auswärtigen amt um die visa vergabe zu
beschleunigen und auch den einsatz von
ausländischen fachkräften in der praxis
für die unternehmen planbarer zu machen
der kollege kronberg erstens in der
mühle fachkräfte ist weit gefasst diesem
bereich sind wir im grenzbereich von
arbeits und fachkräften um das mal ganz
offen zu sagen es ist trotzdem eine
richtig eine richtige regelung zu
verlängern werden das haben in der
koalition auch vereinbart übrigens für
richtige fachkräfte brauchen wir drei
teams das habe ich vorhin vergessen
toleranz technologie und talente an
dieser stelle toleranz der klein richter
gehört auch dazu ich wollte das nur nach
tragen wir müssen einen land sein das
dann auch menschen die chance gibt die
zu uns kommt aber zu ihrer frage wir
sind im gespräch im auswärtigen amt
nicht nur was die westbalkan regelung
betrifft wir müssen ja feststellen dass
viele konsularische abteilung des
auswärtigen amts zu den botschaften
überlaufen sind und deshalb kann nur
eines helfen die einführung des
bundesamts für auswärtige angelegenheit
in brandenburg havel als backoffice um
das zu beschleunigen und das hatten wir
die außenministerin auch so gesagt
sie sehen es gibt keine nachfrage sie
sehen das präsidium hat gewechselt ich
werde aber die praxis der präsidentin
fortsetzen das heißt ich werde
beide fraktionen die noch nicht zum zuge
gekommen sind mit ihrer frage aufrufen
der fragesteller oder die fragestellerin
hat die möglichkeit zu einer nachfrage
und ich lasse maximal zwei weitere
nachfragen hier aus dem mund zu und wenn
wir das geschafft haben endet dann auch
die regierungsbefragung und wir gehen in
die dann entsprechend verkürzte
fragestunde über die nächste frage
stellt der kollege jens beutel für die
fdp
sehr geehrter herr minister in der
korona pandemie gab es einen deutlichen
rückgang an neu abgeschlossenen
ausbildungsverträge wenn wir die jahre
2020 und 21 zu lernen zusammen nehmen
dann sind das fast über 100000
ausbildungsverträge die zurückgegangen
sind gleichzeitig konnten schülerinnen
und schüler auch schwerer ein praktikum
machen die berufliche orientierung hat
ebenfalls in der pandemie gelitten und
wir haben das phänomen was wir jedes
jahr betrachten können auch im letzten
jahr 60.000 unternehmen super sind am
ende übrig geblieben die noch einen
auszubildenden suchen und 20.000 junge
menschen die noch einen ausbildungsplatz
gesucht haben also ein mismatch inc ich
würde sie fragen welche maßnahmen wollen
sie ergreifen um dieses mit matching
entgegenzuwirken und die berufliche
ausbildung weiter zu stärken
natürlich ganz herzlichen dank für die
frage es geht um kurzfristige dinge die
wir nachholen müssen weil corona da war
und zum beispiel die form von
berufsorientierung die sonst gegeben hat
nicht stattgefunden hat aufgrund der
tatsache dass es kaum betriebspraktika
gegeben hat und auch viele instrumente
der bundesagentur für arbeit ist
physisch stattgefunden hätten digital
gemacht werden mussten und damit kann
man viel erreichen aber eben nicht alle
und deshalb haben wir mit den
spitzenverbänden der und der
bundesagentur in der allianz für aus und
weiterbildung auch mit den
gewerkschaften uns vorgenommen in diesem
sommer als sommer der ausbildung der
fahrer kräftig nachzulegen und wo immer
es geht dieses mismatch auch zu
überwinden aber es geht auch um
strukturelle maßnahmen und das geht über
diesen sommer hinaus es geht darum dass
genug betriebliche ausbildungsplätze
auch angeboten werden das ist regional
unterschiedlich in deutschland je nach
wirtschaftlicher lage werden wir müssen
auch feststellen dass viele unternehmen
aber ausbildungsplätze abgebaut haben
betriebliche ausbildung abgebaut haben
andere finden händeringend keine und das
müssen wir besser hinkriegen ich glaube
ein schlüssel dazu von vielen themen ist
bessere berufsorientierung möglichst an
allen schulen übrigens auch an gymnasien
und wenn es nach mir geht ab der siebten
klasse das kann ich nicht alleine
verfügen wir werden das mit der
bundesagentur unterstützen aber ich
würde mir das von allen bundesländern
wünschen ab der siebten klasse arbeit
technik wirtschaft an jeder schule das
hilft mehr berufsbilder kennen zu lernen
und junge menschen frühzeitig auf das
leben vorzubereiten
[Applaus]
eine nachfrage im koalitionsvertrag
haben wir uns darauf geeinigt dass wir
die jugend berufs agenturen auch weiter
ausbauen wollen welchen mehrwert sehen
sie in den jugend berufs agenturen um
das thema ausbildung ebenfalls zu
stärken das ist ein hervorragendes
beispiel dass es in hamburg entstanden
als ein arbeits senator detlef scheele
hieß der jetzt doch chef der
bundesagentur ist und der bürgermeister
wies glaube ich olaf scholz die idee war
in hamburg und die versuchen wir in ganz
deutschland umzusetzen dass junge
menschen im übergang von schule und
beruf nicht in irgendwelche behördlichen
rücken fallen sondern dass behörden so
zusammenarbeiten dass junge menschen die
chance bekommen wo immer es geht auf
ausbildung und wo das nicht gelingt auch
qualifizierung und später ausbildung um
zugang zum arbeitsplatz zu machen das
ist regional unterschiedlich haben wir
euch hat den vorteil dass die kommune
und land sind dass das gut zusammen geht
das ist ein stadtstaat ist es gibt
andere modelle von jugend berufs
agenturen aber wir werden unterstützen
dass wir das flächendeckend es gibt ja
sehr viele inzwischen in deutschland
ausrollen und das ist vernünftig hilfe
aus einer hand mit in verschiedenen
systemen über die jugend
berufsorientierung berufs agenturen zu
organisieren damit die nicht in
irgendwelche behördlichen rücken fallen
sondern wirklich jeder und jede chance
auf eine ausbildung und selbstbestimmtes
leben bekommt
so einer nachfrage hat der kollege jens
herzlichen dank frau präsidentin herr
minister der kollegin katrina hat er die
korona krise angesprochen und sie in
ihrem eingangsstatement auch nochmal
erwähnt dass mit einem starken und
verlässlichen sozialstaat unter anderm
mit dem kurzarbeitergeld er
durchgekommen sind wie ich würde noch
mal ihre vertiefte einschätzung
interessieren wie wird das
kurzarbeitergeld war auch um
ausbildungsplätze zu sichern weil wir
liquidität von betrieben sichergestellt
haben und gab es einen fast im ausland
rückmeldungen zu diesem modell naja
kollege das kann ich bestätigen und ich
glaube das ist eine grundlegende sechs
lektionen wie man über die krone krise
und wirtschaftskrisen die kommunen
hinaus lernen sollte es gab ja mal eine
politische debatte wie viel sozialstaat
kann sich eine erfolgreiche
marktwirtschaft leisten und wenn wir
jetzt erlebt dass es ausgerechnet der
sozialstaat war der in krisenzeiten
nicht nur den beschäftigten sozial
geholfen hat sondern den unternehmen
geholfen hat und nach allen
internationalen studien kann ich sagen
oder kommentaren die ich von außen
mindeste von arbeitsminister aus andern
ländern bekomme die haben versucht in
europa unser instrument zu kopieren das
instrument der kurzarbeit
das hat auch ökonomische funktion ökonom
sprechen von automatischen
stabilisatoren die ein sozialstaat parat
hat in schlechten zeiten auch die
gesamtwirtschaftliche nachfrage
abzufedern es hat unternehmen geholfen
fachkräfte an bord zu behalten und nach
der krise mit denen wieder durchstarten
zu können und sie haben recht ich habe
das hier in diesem hause auch schon mal
gesagt ich habe vor kurzem gelernt in
einer schalte mit amerika ich war in
harvard aber nicht wie karl lauterbach
und hab da studiert so das war nur eine
digitale schalter und das war aber mit
wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlern ich
habe gelernt dass der begriff kurzarbeit
mittlerweile in amerika ein gutes leben
wort geworden dass wir das gute deutsche
worte kindergarten und ist eine chiffre
für gutes krisen-management die
lektionen dürfen nicht vergessen es geht
nicht um sozialstaat gegen erfolgreiche
wirtschaft sondern beides muss gut
miteinander funktionieren und das ist
eine lektion auch der korona pandemie
für mich als bundesarbeitsminister das
ist durchaus nicht nur eine soziale
sondern auch eine ökonomische
stabilisierende wirkung hatte dass wir
an stark 12 statt haben
die kollegin meike wohlfahrt das wort zu
einer nachfrage
jetzt glaube ich genau herr minister sie
haben jetzt sehr lange über
berufsausbildung geredet und sie haben
auch eine maßnahme genannt die im
koalitionsvertrag verankert ist das
irgendwie jugend berufs agenturen die
berufsorientierung ab klasse 7 findet
man nicht im koalitionsvertrag das
scheint mir eher ihr wunsch ihr
persönlicher wünsche zu sein eine andere
maßnahme steht aber im koalitionsvertrag
die haben sie jetzt gar nicht genannt
das ist die sogenannte
ausbildungsgarantie ich habe mich schon
häufig gefragt angesichts der tatsache
dass die nunmehr seit über zehn jahren
mehr ausbildungsplätze haben als
nachfrager zur ausbildungsplätzen ist
das die richtige maßnahme also wie
konkret ist der planungsstand dann
werden sie die ausbildungsgarantie denn
umsetzen oder ist das thema vom tisch
weil sie es ja gerade gar nicht genannt
haben kollegen ich glaube ich habe sie
vor den frau kloses meine zeugen weil
sie sich für das thema interessiert
einmal erwähnt die ausbildungsgarantie
sie haben aber recht die berufs ein team
nicht angesprochen habe ist deshalb
durch einen koalitionsvertrag nicht nur
weil sie nur meine meinung ist sondern
weil das in der kompetenz der
bundesländer liegt an ihren schulen ab
der siebten klasse so etwas zu machen
ich finde es nur als arbeitsminister
total richtig das zu machen und
vielleicht können wir gemeinsam in die
richtung wirken die ausbildungsgarantie
wird kommen aber sie können nicht sich
das als eine maßnahme vorstellen als ein
hebel sondern das ist ein setting von
maßnahmen das wir einsetzen wollen mit
einem ziel nämlich dass wir möglichst
jedem jungen menschen die chance geben
auf ausbildung und wo das nicht gelingt
dafür zu sorgen dass erstmalig ins
bergfreie fallen und dann auch in
ausbildung kommen können und dazu werde
ich in diesem jahr vorschläge machen die
werden wir dann stück für stück umsetzen
ich wollte nur aufklärend sagen dass das
nicht mehr eine hebel weil wir regional
zum beispiel sehr unterschiedliche
situationen haben auf dem
ausbildungsmarkt sie haben bereiche in
deutschland in denen treten sie keinen
auszubildenden mehr als
mittelständisches unternehmen und sie
haben bereiche in denen junge leute
händeringend sich die finger wund
schreiben um ausbildung zu haben und
deshalb gilt es für diese
ausbildungsgarantie nicht nur einen
schalter zu haben sondern ein setting
von instrumenten und dafür zu sorgen
dass das auch umgesetzt werden kann
nein nachfragen was wir jetzt nicht zu
die nächste und auch letzte frage in der
regierungsbefragung stellt der kollege
matthias leben vielen dank frau
präsidentin sehr verehrter herr
bundesminister heil lieber robertus sie
haben ja eben gesagt dass sie bereit
sind über verbesserungen zu diskutieren
ob es reicht oder ob es nicht reicht und
in ihrem renten paket 1 haben sie
nunmehr vor
erwerbsminderungsrentner rinnen und
ländern also menschen die wegen
chronischer krankheiten nicht arbeiten
können höhere erwerbsminderungsrente in
form eines zuschlages zu gewähren das
ist notwendig weil spd und grüne im jahr
2001 eine rentenreform gemacht haben die
dafür gesorgt hat dass diese chronisch
kranken menschen deutlich niedrigere
ansprüche bekommen haben nun haben sie
vorgeschlagen
7,5 beziehungsweise 4,5 prozent zuschlag
zu machen für alle die zwischen 2001 und
2008 10 in eine rente gingen mussten
jetzt frage ich sie wie begründet bzw
wie berechnet sich denn der
ausgabendeckel von 2,6 milliarden euro
für diese viel zu niedrigen zuschläge
und zweitens erwecken sie den eindruck
dass diese jahre lang vergessene gruppe
mit einer sehr hohen
armutsgefährdung und so traurig das ist
auch einer sehr kurzen
lebenserwartung gleichgestellt würde und
so traurig das ist sie wollen die bis
2024 im regen stehen lassen also warum
20 24 und vor allen dingen
wie hoch wie berechnet sich der zuschlag
sehr geehrter burgfeld ich habe sehr
aufmerksamen ihrer rede zur ersten
lesung gelauscht ich finde es schade
dass sie den positiven teil aufgrund der
kürze der zeit heute weg lassen mussten
denn wir sind uns ja im kern einig dass
diese längst überfällige verbesserung
der erwerbsgeminderten leistungen dann
etwas ist was fortschritt im lebensalter
von menschen bedeuten wird und sie haben
die punkte angesprochen die im
parlamentarischen verfahren diskutiert
werden da geht es um die frage wann kann
das technisch umgesetzt werden und zu
welchem zeitpunkt das zweite ist wie es
die höhe da kann ich dem bundestag nicht
vorgreifen wir haben einen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt die begründung der
bundesregierung können sie der
begründung des gesetzestextes jawohl
entnehmen das parlamentarische verfahren
läuft ich hoffe es wird bald
abgeschlossen und wie immer das ausgeht
es wird der bundestag entscheiden ich
glaube es gibt am montag nächster woche
der haushaltswoche dazu erstmal eine
anhörung ihres ausschusses und ich gehe
davon aus dass wir dann auch schnell
eine einigung herbeiführen werden aber
im grundsatz herburg volt über die höhen
kann man den bestreiten und dass sie
immer mehr wollen als andere parteien
ist hinlänglich bekannt das ist klar
noch einen drauf aber ich will an dieser
stelle sagen in der richtung ist das ein
riesenfortschritt für drei millionen
menschen in deutschland die endlich nach
einem leben von arbeit das unterbrochen
wurde von krankheit oder von unfällen
oder weil man eine behinderung bekommen
hat tatsächlich besser gestellt werden
und das ist glaube ich ein großer
sozialer fortschritt herburg welt das
hatten sie ja auch in der letzten rede
gesagt bei allen wünschen die sie eben
auch noch mal unterstrichen
soweit die befragung der bundesregierung
mit hubertus heil bundesarbeitsminister
wir verlassen jetzt fürs erste dem
bundestag weil gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach sich auch äußern möchte zur
impfstrategie
[Musik]